Netflix is streaming The Saga Wars on
his YouTube channel on Sunday February
26th The Screen Actor skills ceremony is
usually a great predictor for the Oscars
but not always you may remember some of
these famous performances that got
snubbed
Kerry joji fukunaga's 2015 film beasts
of no Nation a drama about child
soldiers in West Africa has a
distinction of being Netflix's first
ever original feature film it's possible
that Academy members were resistant to
awarding a streaming release which could
explain why the critically acclaimed
film didn't receive a single Oscar
nomination despite significant award
success elsewhere particularly for Idris
elba's performance as a commandant all
of you that have never been listened to
before and have seen your family killed
you now have something that stands for
you of course another Factor could also
explain the snub CNM blamed it on the
Academy's racism 2016 was the second
year in a row where all the acting
nominees were white resulting in the
hashtag Oscars so white controversy some
people are born to be leaders others are
born to be followers and others are just
waiting to be dying Alba sags only black
anomaly that year won the Guild's best
supporting actor award despite his Oscar
snub for the Oscar for best supporting
actor that year ultimately went to mark
rylance for bridge of spies the second
sag winner in history to not be
nominated at the Oscars was Emily Blunt
for her performance as Evelyn Abbott in
the 2018 horror Blockbuster a quiet
place the academy doesn't always
recognize great acting in horror movies
but a quiet place was such a hit that it
seemed like blunt had a genuine shot at
a nomination
with me and and then I had to go and do
laundry and
category confusion may have been another
obstacle for blunt she and co-star
director John Krasinski were originally
pitched in the lead acting categories
but switched to the supporting columns
Midway through campaign season blunt won
the 2018 sag Award for best supporting
actress which speaks to sag's own snoops
that year Regina King heartbreaking as
Sharon rivers and if Beale Street could
talk was a highly deserving Oscar winner
for best supporting actress burst wasn't
nominated by The Guild
there are debates to be had over who
most deserved the best actor Oscar in
2021 both posthumous saguena shadwick
Boseman as musician Levy green and
moraine's black bottom and Oscar winner
Anthony Hopkins as dementia patient
Anthony in the father delivered
incredible performances however the way
the Oscars telecast handled Hopkins
Victory places this among the most
egregious snubs in recent Oscar history
our all right color
let me see you fix that straighten that
out Bozeman was seen as such a sure bet
to win that Oscar attendees were given
nfts of his face whereas best picture is
traditionally the final Award of the
night this time best actor was saved for
last presumably to send viewers off on
the emotional high of the late black
panther Stars family accepting the award
I Got Talent
if my daddy hadn't known I was gonna
turnout like this he would have named me
Gabriel when Bozeman didn't win foiling
the send off the show had seemingly
planned there was serious backlash to
make matters even more Awkward Hopkins
wasn't there given that it was 4 am in
his native Wales and the academy
wouldn't let him accept the award via
Zoom despite the ongoing covid-19
pandemic
The Screen Actors Guild members are much
bigger fans of Viola Davis and the
academies both groups awarded her the
best supporting actress awards for
playing Rose Lee Maxson in Denzel
Washington's 2016 adaptation of the
August Wilson play fences however Davis
has yet to win a Best Actress Oscar
despite having SAG Awards for playing
Abilene Clark in 2011's the help and the
total role in 2020's mahraini's black
bottom he was kind
he was smart you is important Davis's
performance and the help lost to Meryl
Streep who won her third Oscar for
playing Margaret Thatcher in the
otherwise mediocre The Iron Lady Davis
and Ma rainey's black bottom lost to
another three-time Oscar winner Francis
McDormand for her performance in Nomad
land okay what nobody else do ma was the
first don't you forget it it's worth
noting that the screen actor's guild is
one of many awards bodies to nominate
Davis for playing General namiska in
Gina Prince by the woods 2021 historical
epic the woman King but the woman king
failed to Garner a single Oscar
nomination
so why did Meryl Streep Win For The Iron
Lady well the film at the backing of
Harvey Weinstein who was at the height
of his ability to bulldoze his way into
most major Oscar races a more charitable
read of the situation however is that
Oscar voters Felt Street was robbed
three years earlier for her performance
in Dallas John Patrick shanley's
adaptation of his Tony winning play
sister Aloysius is among the richest
royal streepers played and would have
made a more deserving third Oscar win
for the legendary actress
I can fight you
you will lose the performance of Beats
dreams for the Best Actress Oscar that
year was also a sag award-winning one
just in a different category Kay
Winslet's work as a Nazi concentration
cam guard Hannah Schmitz and the reader
earn the best supporting actress nod
from Sac but was considered a lead role
by the academy and ultimately won that
category in retrospect it doesn't look
great that a movie that tried to sell an
extremely questionable relationship
between a teenage boy and a grown woman
as a very genuine Love Story beats out a
movie about standing up to child abusers
if Streep's 2012 Oscar victory over
Davis was due to people feeling she was
owed for Dallas then Winslet's 2008
campaign beat house strip in large part
due to the sense that she was owed for
her whole career up to that point the
reader was Winslet sixth Oscar
nomination and many felt she should have
won one for one of her earlier nominated
roles such as Clementine Krasinski in
Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind
Rose to which bukasa in Titanic or
Marianne dashwood in Sense and
Sensibility
it's a claimed performance as a
hyper-emotional middle child in Angeli's
1995 Jane Austen adaptation was only her
second feature film role following her
debut in Peter Jackson's true crime
drama Heavenly Creatures the previous
year Winslet's best supporting actress
victory at the age of 20 made her the
youngest sag Award winner in history at
the Oscars however Winslet ended up
losing to Mira Sorvino in the middle of
the road Woody Allen Fleck Mighty
Aphrodite
ties can happen at the Oscars but
they're exceedingly rare it's only
happened six times on Academy Awards
history one wonders how close the
academy was to another tie at the 1998
ceremony the year The Saga Wars had its
first tie in the best supporting actress
race the Dual sag owners went to Kim
Basinger as Lynn Bracken in LA
Confidential and Gloria Stewart as Rose
Dawson Calvert in Titanic Basinger
ultimately took the Oscar Stuart who
played rose as an old woman and Kate
Winslet who played rose to the majority
of the film both lost their respective
Oscar races basing a one for skillfully
evoking old Hollywood glamor in a gritty
neo-noir but Stuart had been acting
since the 1930s was actual old Hollywood
glamor the awards ties are statistical
anomalies in this case maybe it would
have been Justified
in 1996 the Oscars and SAG Awards didn't
agree on who gave the most worthy
supporting performances of the year not
only did Winslet win best supporting
actress at sag yet lose at the Oscars
but Ed Harris as NASA flight director
Jean Kranz in Apollo 13 when best
supporting actor at sag only for the
Academy to prefer Kevin Spacey in The
Usual Suspects when it comes to the
question of which performance would you
actually want to watch today it goes
without saying that Harris easily beats
Spacey we never lost an American in
space we're sure as hell not going to
lose one on my watch failure is not an
option but even if we ignore all of the
sorted details we now know about Spacey
Harris would have been a worthy Oscar
winner for his powerful portrayal of
heroism and professionalism under
extreme pressure this was Harris's first
Oscar nomination he was later nominated
for best supporting actor for 1998's The
Truman Show and 2002's The Hours as well
as best actor for 2000's Pollock he's
one of those actors who's been doing
such great work for so long that is
strange that he hasn't yet won an Oscar
two of the strongest performances in
Peter Jackson's Lord of the Rings
trilogy Andy Circus a Smiggle slash
Gollum and Sean Aston as Samwise gamji
were nominated by the academy or sag
though sag did nominate all three films
and the ward Return of the King best
Ensemble the questions of whether motion
capture acting counts likely killed
circuses Awards chances and the general
Ensemble nature of the trilogy made
singling out individual performers
difficult the one individual performance
in the trilogy to get significant Awards
recognition was Sir Ian McKellen as the
wizard Gandalf the Gray in the first
film 2001's a Fellowship of the Ring he
won best supporting actor at the SAG
Awards and was nominated in the same
category at the Oscars ultimately losing
to gym broadbands in Iris but McKellen
won he would have been the first openly
gay man to win an acting Oscar wizard is
never late from their Baggins
noise here earlier he arrives precisely
when he means to comparisons can be
drawn between mcallen's nomination and
Alec Guinness's nomination for the
original Star Wars The Academy might not
take acting in a fantasy movie seriously
very often but when they do they seem
drawn to wisened Mentor figures played
by beloved older actors
Martin scorsese's 2002 historical crime
epic Gangs of New York was nominated for
10 Academy Awards but didn't win any of
them in Oscar's history only 1977's a
turning point and 1985's a color purple
had more nominations 11 without a win
Gangs of New York as one of scores says
he's more divisive films it seems to
have the Academy's respect but not much
of its love even critics who weren't
crazy about the film as a whole however
were enamored with Daniel Day Lewis's
performance as a xenophobic gang leader
William cutting AKA Bill the Butcher to
defeat my enemy
I extinguish his life
and consume him as I consume these
Flames Island's favorite method actor
eventually won Oscars for similarly
transformative performances as Daniel
Plainview in 2007's There Will Be Blood
and as Abraham Lincoln in 2012's Lincoln
in addition to his 1990 Oscar for my
left foot in which he played a man with
cerebral palsy who has only the use of
his left foot the best actor Oscar that
year ultimately went to Adrian Brody in
The Pianist a film which remains
controversial due to the actions of
director Roman Polanski
Johnny Depp may be a polarizing figure
but it's difficult to argue against the
fact that his performance as Captain
Jack Sparrow in Pirates of the Caribbean
the Curse of the Black Pearl was a
defining moment in a career that has
gotten bogged down in repetitive
collaborations with Tim Burton that
yield ever diminishing returns you are
without doubt the worst pirate I've ever
heard of
but you have heard of me the idea that
Pirates of the Caribbean the Curse of
the Black Pearl a movie based on a
Disneyland attraction could be in
serious Awards contention at all let
alone against Sean Penn and Mystic River
and Bill Murray in Lost in Translation
is entirely due to the incredible job
Depp did as Captain Jack Sparrow or the
more impressive that he gots in on the
strength of his chaotic comedic energy
even that it was bodies far too often
Overlook comedic performances
on paper Eddie Murphy's performance as
soul singer Jimmy Thunder early and
Dream Girls Bill condon's 2006 film
adaptation of the hit Broadway musical
seems like a lock for the Oscar it's had
everything Academy voters love a beloved
comedic actor taking on a serious role a
character inspired by a real person a
drug addiction story and the revelation
of unexpected musical talent and Murphy
was great in the role stealing every
scene Jennifer Hudson hadn't already
stolen Murphy won the SAG Award for best
supporting actor as well as the Golden
Globe and Critics Choice Award he
ultimately lost the Oscar to Alan Arkin
as a ground bar Edwin Hoover in Little
Miss Sunshine how did Arkin win
affection for Little Miss Sunshine as a
whole has definitely helped the Indie
comedy was nominated for best picture
while Dream Girls wasn't then there's
the Norbit Factor don't you think I
realized what's going on here miss
starring in a terrible movie while
campaigning for an Oscar didn't help
Murphy's chances although Norbert
started the NASCAR nomination for best
makeup the following year
[Music]